ken is an absolute superstar we've had
all sorts of wonderful people in the mid
devon cycling club but to be honest ken
is that the absolutely best Kenned you
are the man without you this club with
anything congratulations blow done you
really deserve this I came glad to see
you back on your bike again we really
missed you and looking forward to some
more right here I've known 10 for many
many years Kenny's mid devon candy
cycling what can I serve I came here the
best I can ice cracking down you're
amazing thanks for your hard work at the
club and your help in France earlier
this year thank you I'm so pleased to
say a few words that cane he's helped me
a lot cycling I've really respect the
man and following him and trying to keep
up with him when i first started has
been an ideal experience why i just hope
he keeps going and I can keep going with
it Cain you're an amazing man and
amazing cyclist who looks after us all
thank you thank you Ken you're an
amazing contribute to the club and a
really nice fella so thank you very much
from yesterday encouraged to go on to be
professionals from all the assistance
he's done he helped him with the the net
road networks and for all the cyclist
he's encouraged for all of his that you
cycle encouraged to get into working in
cycling big thank you I don't know what
we'd have done without you
you